tanks missile systems
and tens of thousands of troops facing
ukraine in the north
and the south built as a series of
routine exercises
it was in fact one of the biggest
mobilizations of russian forces
in decades moscow was making no effort
to hide it
in any conflict situation
mr putin tries to recall western
counterparts
that he can easily burn the
planet then just a few weeks later
it was all over just as suddenly as it
began
russia's defense ministry announced all
troops would return to base
and all this without an obvious outcome
to its original military buildup
so what exactly is russia doing why this
huge show of force from vladimir putin
let's find out number one it's about
ukraine i mean it is about
uh frustration in moscow with zelensky
and the the expectations in moscow that
he would make concessions but i do think
it's also
a test to see the reaction of the west
and in particular the biden
administration
and just a way to uh remind people that
russia is is here russia is uh
militarily
strong certainly compared to ukraine
uh and and russia is in principle
willing to use a tools
certainly there was no shortage of
attention and demonstrative shows of
respect for putin
under biden's predecessor donald trump
their ultimately fruitless summit in
helsinki
reminded many observers of 1970s cold
war diplomacy
rather than a meeting between the leader
of a superpower and a country whose
economy
is more than ten times smaller when
trump was elected that in moscow you
know people were popping the champagne
courts
and uh when biden was elected that that
certainly didn't happen
at all and i don't think he expects uh
uh to get what he got out of trump who
said that basically he trusts putin more
than the u.s
intelligence services this new u.s
president
is a veteran not only the obama
administration but also
decades on the senate foreign affairs
committee and he soon struck
a very different note so you know
vladimir putin you think he's a killer
i do this to a response strident even by
the kremlin standards
had really stung in a way that many
rounds of sanctions hadn't
not in personal terms because it
suggested something broader
an attempt to isolate the kremlin
diplomatically a suggestion
that here was a leader the west couldn't
and wouldn't do business with
within days russian tanks were rolling
first in small groups
still passed offers regular exercises
then progressively more
causing former nato generals to worry
out loud about the growing threat of a
russian incursion into ukraine
i think that there probably were various
scenarios
i'm not sure that they from the very
beginning decided we're absolutely not
going to attack under any circumstances
in my vision the main
goal of these exercises was
to make a new burger chip
for the west and this bergen keep
will be the possibility
of a big war in ukraine
politics and not a perceived military
threat from nato
was behind these troop movements says
alexander goltz he's convinced
it was actually russia that forced nato
to truly engage with ukraine
by launching hostilities back in 2014
it's absolutely clear that
nato militaries started their
deployments
after 2015.
ukraine called up its reservists and
troops and repeated mantra-like
that they would not let themselves be
provoked into shooting first
they were desperate not to give an
excuse for russian military action
many civilians in eastern ukraine had
their cases packed to leave in a hurry
if needed
meanwhile u.s legislators advocated to
increase support for ukraine's military
to 300 million dollars a year and
crucially that support would now likely
include
lethal weapons not just the defensive
equipment previously provided
something ukraine has been pushing for
for years unsuccessfully
european leaders such as france's
emmanuel macron who had previously tried
to engage with russia and mediate
suddenly struck a more decisive tone
europe he said
would not tolerate any new military
action on ukrainian territory
crucially though europe shied away from
spelling out what price the kremlin
would pay
for intervention in ukraine and there
was no promise talk construction
of the nordstrom 2 pipeline as many in
ukraine had hoped
[Applause]
vladimir putin's eagerly awaited annual
state of the nation address
it had a lot of swagger for lawmakers
but surprisingly little detail on the
one
issue occupying mines around the world
ukraine was barely mentioned next day
russia's defense ministry announced the
end of the quote exercises
saying that all forces would now return
to base but what has this costly
escalation actually achieved
it's no doubt that all these
attempts of uh bergey was
very successful biden called
by the suggested meeting
so now who will say that
mr putin is isolated dictator
for god's sake everybody wants to speak
to him
i think uh that that actually uh moscow
has come out of this feeling
stronger like it was probably worth it
the military instrument is also
something that
uh the west is very reluctant to respond
to in kind
so it's kind of an ideal instrument and
and one where
where russia believes that it's strong
it's willing to use that strength
both in terms of show of force and in
terms of actual
um military military actions
west's unwillingness to use force the
argument goes could actually now be
encouraging vladimir putin to use it
or at least threaten to russia's
neighbours chief among them ukraine
are now calling for the west to make
vladimir putin pay a long-term political
price
for this piece of brinkmanship otherwise
they say
europe will have to get used to this
kind of diplomacy